all right what's up guys this video is
extremely important so listen up
I need more Instagram followers okay
so right now I have about one hundred
and thirty thousand followers on
Instagram which may seem like a lot but
Selena Gomez has 142 million followers
million all I'm asking for is one I'm
not even being selfish I just want one
just one million that's dying come on I
found out that makeup is super trendy
and if you know makeup and you're like a
makeup guru and you make makeup videos
you're instantly a celebrity so I'm
gonna become a makeup guru let's go okay
so this is Kennedy she is the expert
that's gonna turn me into a makeup guru
today if you don't know who Kennedy is
she just blew up on YouTube blew up on
Instagram what did you do on YouTube
that made you go viral I grew up
watching YouTube know if you watch
something enough it's like studying
something so I studied YouTube so I
didn't know it was studying at the time
until I mean the YouTube channel and I
was like wow this feels really natural I
know exactly what to do that's what I
did first together kind of put you on
the map did have to do with makeup right
yeah I did
that's it yeah I also have an Instagram
account where I didn't makeup tutorials
don't do that anymore so but I did do
that and I like I I do people make a lot
so oh my can they stay in wall by
congratulations thank you got the job
we're gonna make this video becoming a
beauty guru today what I want you to do
you need a makeup collection obviously
because you can't do makeup without
makeup expert we're gonna go get some
makeup let's do it
all right so we get to the store I'm
feeling pretty excited because I'm about
to get my you know makeup palette and
I'm gonna have a whole array of makeup
so the first thing we need sound Asian
and Eric has no idea what foundation is
foundation is powder no I mean they have
powder foundations really
oh let's go find foundation why are
there so many basically all I'm going to
do is figure out which one matches my
face this color you can test it on your
face you want to see know what if I
blend it yeah actually it's really good
really yeah you're lying
yeah we're like that might be a little
whitest one the next thing we need
concealer and once again Eric has
literally no idea what it is that's the
same thing no it's not
now people watching might think like I
was trying to be a fool and like
struggle in the makeup store but I was
really trying to focus like I put a
hundred percent of my brain into trying
to figure out what Kennedy was saying
and I I had no idea what was coming out
of her mouth so Eric keeps on putting
the testers in the bag instead of the
actual products that we're going to buy
he kept dropping things
oh my god it's like a magic drink it's
gone okay so we're just not doing it
right
[Music]
okay next is powder I know that just set
all of it so it doesn't move around
makeup mousse what so I'm really losing
hope at this so I started taking over
and doing things my own way I'll learn
about all the makeup stuff later I think
the important part is putting on the
makeup so I think I'm still in the clear
and I can I can do this I think I can
still succeed
so we back it all up went to pay for it
and you know the price keeps going up
and going up Canady bought me $500 worth
of makeup not a big deal though right I
think I have high hopes okay I believe
in myself I'm gonna work hard James
Charles watch out so now we have the
makeup and I'm sitting here with Eric so
the next part into becoming a successful
for you guru is of course to start her
YouTube career we're gonna be following
in the footsteps of a very popular
beauty guru during YouTube they want the
only James Charles Hannah he has a video
on his channel where he tried to teach
his friends makeup through a wall so
he's basically just giving a verbal
instruction this is weird not being able
to see you yeah I feel really alone
right now I'm just talking away all are
you looking at it yeah
yeah are you ready yeah
are you sure you're ready yeah let's do
it whoo first things first foundation
grab the foundation do you have it wait
is it the thick thick bottle yes and
then you want to grab the orange sponge
got it and then you want to open the
foundation whoa this is the best feeling
thing I've ever felt in my life
great try not to be a scigirl for two
seconds all right so you want to take
the sponge and then open the foundation
took the cap off and you want to squirt
like three pumps on your hand on the
back of your hand it's not sporting make
it through now you want to dip your
finger in that and dot it all over your
face it feels disgusting the second way
oh my god I look in the same I think I
did this
wait Kennedy am I supposed to look crazy
oh did I put too much too much oh god
just start blending it out with orange
pie oh my gosh
I rub the missing ring tap it right the
orange thing oh you have it don't rub
tap it back all around your face make
sure you really get it are you sure you
got me the right color
I don't know Eric it was dressed well I
looks like like sick I look like it's
fine that's what bronzer doesn't work
all right next is concealer do you
remember all the concealer looks like so
you want to open that carefully make
sure it doesn't splash everywhere oh it
splashes you want to draw two
upside-down triangles under your eyes
there's great triangles okay and you
also want to do a line gun down your
nose a little bit on your chin and then
do a little bit
on the sides of your nose okay and they
also ever put them on your eyelids I
keep putting it back in Kennedy okay I'm
telling you to keep one of you back in
so why do you keep putting it back in
eyelids so I close my eye
yes no no you just put someone you're
doing it was right before I just lower
your eyes flaps them on there you want
to do an upside down triangle on the
center of your forehead okay for a
second I thought I've been doing the
wrong triangles okay triangles actually
triangles oh my god wait triangles
aren't these you need to finish the
triangle right and what I've only been
doing two lines like I've been making an
end
oh you fill it in oh you feel this
looked good okay so wait let me fill it
in Kennedy Oh what do you need right
tell me the concealer and then blood gas
fast as you can
Dodi applies no we're just gonna drive
and now middle of my forehead
okay that's rush now you want to take
the blending brush and smack it all out
I'm still coloring into my triangle okay
I'm done
now what it's extra Mike blended in as
fast as you can where blended into what
you're standing all over well that's the
eye area when you see a person's face
where you make up do they have triangles
on their face no but why did I make a
triangles thing why do you make the
triangles to go line if I'm blending it
every blending it right now everywhere
three blend again yeah good how do I
blend my eyelids yeah
can I rub it at all or at the down
should be dabbing this is exhausting how
long does this usually take you every
day oh wow my jawline is definitely not
blind look I'm noticing things that like
okay now you want to take the black
brush swirl it in the powder and put
that all over your face I mean it finds
the bronzer bronzer Laura seller is it
the swirly one now there's a bronzer
here like they match okay
jaundice Becca I remember backup okay
great some roll the brush around in it
and then top the excess off it's like
tap tap tap the brush tap the UM classic
front of the brush on to like the
airport you're holding the brush right
yeah so you want to tap the handle of
the brush on like with something so
that's the excess of the brush stick out
your arm and that's half the handle of
the brush on your arms on your arm I did
it gonna blow that up a near temple and
then on to like the perimeter of your
forehead and then do the same thing on
the other side of your face this is so
relaxing not for me so now we're gonna
do blush so then you want to gently
sweep it across your cheeks
so now you want to pick that orange
sponge again we're gonna make the
contour drag the down like to the bottom
of your mouth so then do not to the
other side done and then you want to
also look like a joker is that whatever
supposed to look like sure all right now
I'm gonna do eyebrows so this is gonna
be kind of a hardware I can't really
describe this that all to you but you
just want to fill in your eyebrows make
them look better wow it's like I'm
growing hair they look really hairy now
I kind of like it it's like yo first
thing you see eyebrows so you want to
grab all of the eyeshadow brushes and
the eyeshadow palette so pick whichever
one like whichever combination that you
like and now just we're clear just sweep
it back and forth and blend it out
really well so you want to take the
sparkly color that you wanted to use and
then you want to Pat that on your eyelid
where the blue isn't alright so now you
might take the big fluffy brush and
brush all the powder away why did we do
that
we never used the line I made a line and
now I'm getting rid of the line yeah
because it's a residue that the Potter
leaves that's sharpened with the contour
and the highlighter and then rubber tops
the tops or cheek bone we're done yeah
I'm blending done you wanna grab liquid
eyeliner so you want to start at the
outer corner of your eye and make up a
line going towards the end of your
eyebrow that's where the line to the
eyebrow I've connected my eyebrow to my
axis now what this is taking so long
how long make up for it
[Music]
last step finally lips so just go over
your natural lip line just a little bit
I did it already yeah the whole mouth no
now the whole mouth you told me to just
outline alright can I reveal it to you
review it yes please alright this is the
most important part because this will
determine if I can become a makeup guru
because if I can put on makeup that
means I got it I'm feeling pretty
confident
alright alright ready it's not bad that
doesn't it was nothing like how I
pictured it it looks like you slept in
your makeup for three days there's just
a little line of highlight which is what
I told you - oh boy
yes being a makeup guru isn't for me and
um even though I haven't gained any
followers what I have gained is an
appreciation for makeup artist so I
guess that's worth something I failed
this time but guess what I'm gonna find
something else and I'm gonna get to a
million followers I don't know when I
don't know how I don't know why
[Music]
you